[Musica]
bellissimo essere qui oggi poi per un
fallito parlare dopo una donna di grande
successo come sonia peronaci quindi
grazie al team di tex per aver militato
qua oggi io mi presento sono andrea
visconti e sono innanzitutto marito di
mia moglie francesca quella santa donna
sono papà di due bambini splendidi
rischiano filippo e riccardo è da un
mese a questa parte anche di una bimba
finalmente si riuscì a fare una femmina
si chiama diletta però oggi non vi
vorrei parlare del fallimento dell'amia
start up quanto più del successo del
fallimento dell'amia start up che si
chiamava simba ed era un sistema che
serviva per pagare nei negozi senza fare
code alla cassa abbiamo anticipato prima
abbiamo vinto share tecnico un talent
show di italia 1
abbiamo vinto alcuni premi tra cui
quello di partner abbiamo rifiuta di
investimenti insomma le cose erano
partite molto bene ma nonostante questo
alla fine la start up e non è andata
come ci aspettavamo ed è fallita ma
certo del fatto che a fallire fosse
stata la startup punto e non ne ho io i
miei soci
ho voluto proprio raccontare ai miei
figli quest'anno a questa cosa che avevo
capito
e siccome i figli sono i bambini piccoli
o pensate di farla con una vita di farlo
con una video fiaba che un po il
linguaggio sono più adatto per per i
bambini ma essendo miei figli dei
bambini dei nativi digitali
la fiaba è diventato un video sui social
punto perché lo strumento del video
digitale mi sembrava più adatto a dei
bambini i nativi digitali e poi
caricando sui miei profili social questo
video è diventato siamo i poker è
diventato virale ed è finito su tutti i
giornali sulle radio sulle televisioni
sulle televisioni
ve lo so capire chi di voi ha visto
questa fiaba sentito parlare di questa
notizia
direi perfetto siete aumentati rispetto
a prima
non vale che se l'avete sentito quello
che fa ovviamente allora siccome
qualcuno però ha detto che ha visto la
fiaba oppure ha sentito questa notizia
per vedere se è vero adesso mi farò
qualche domandina però siccome non sono
così bastato come sembra sono domande a
risposta multipla così sopra vi agevole
nella risposta allora sono tre domande
più era quindi una cosa abbastanza
veloce la di che cosa parlava alla fiaba
ah ecco dovete rispondere che
pubblicherò una risposta per volta
dovete rispondere a sei persone che
quella sia quella giusta
dovete dispone da quel momento aspettare
tutto ciò è troppo facile quindi un po
bastardo da solo o di cosa parlava la
fiaba di due start upper in cerca di
finanziamenti che vincono un premio chi
vota questa nessuno quindi avete ha
un'attenzione abbiamo l'uomo
dell'ultim'ora due marinai che vogliono
attraversare l'oceano rivolta questa
mano in più si sta alzando anche dalla
curva sud molto bene
un unico al real atto che conoscere le
persone meravigliose più non vale perché
tu hai ai retroscena ma in realtà la
risposta giusta è la seconda due marinai
che vogliono attraversare l'oceano
questa era facile sentiamo più sul
difficile che cosa significa fallire
significa sbagliare a chi vota la la uno
la busta numero uno nessuno
molto bene non essere capaci di fare un
somma abbiamo capito chi vota la numero
2 però dovette mutu c'è non è che vale
qualcosa dovete votarlo perché sennò non
abbiate paura di fallire come avete
visto inseguire un sogno e cadere
miseramente un po come il tizio della
fotografia ecco qui qualche mano in più
si alza in realtà era la numero uno nel
senso che è la radice della parola
fallire significa falso sbagliato
infatti tutti falliamo perché tutti
sbagliamo ma l'importante non è quello
di non sbagliare mai di non fallire mai
ma quello di sapersi sempre rialzare da
d'ogni proprio fallimento cercando di
trasformarli in successo anche perché se
abbiamo paura di fallire o di sbagliare
non puoi mai sperimentare no se non
sperimentino
mai sogna direi che aveva sperimentato
in tempi non sospetti una cosa che aveva
possibilità di fallire effettivamente
invece il successo che cos'è successo
paura di cadere ma voglia di volare col
jingle dice qualcosa che è successo
tutti quelli che votano l'ultima perché
vediamo come l'ultima far succedere
tutto ciò che desideriamo comunque piene
di asteroidi e mette paura
molto bene molto bene in realtà era la
numero 2
questa è una cosa che voluto dire questo
video in questo video fiaba che
l'etimologia della parola successo
significa che una determinata cosa è
successa è accaduta le persone quindi
non possono fallire o meglio hanno
successo per il semplice fatto che
succede alla ciò che ci sono e tutti i
giorni abbiamo gli occhi e ci siamo
chi è che non è indovinata neanche una
perché non ne ha votato neanche una
scandalosa
chi invece che la zecca di tutte che non
è vero
1 ok abbiamo attenzione ok passiamo a
domanda più difficile su che abbiamo
addirittura quattro risposte possibili
niente più difficile cosa significa
significa fare l'imprenditore alzarsi la
mattina con la voglia di cambiare il
mondo
pochi poca gente romantica qua qualche
donna stanza normale andare a letto la
sera felici per ciò che si sta
costruendo siete tanto romantici qua
salerno ormai pagare le tasse
qui non pagate le tasse vedo solo in
pochi molto bene fare grana a palate
non fate grande neanche palati però
direi che o quantomeno non tutti bene a
questa virata sono tutte giuste era
affatto per agevolare chi non ha giocato
neanche una prima almeno questo dominata
ok passiamo l'ultima domanda quella
decisiva
tipo quella del calcetto chi segna
questa invece tutto il giorno del tuo
matrimonio non l'hai preparato come
donna che si rispetti l'aveva preparata
nei minimi dettagli
scelta la data estiva in modo tale da
far scongiurare i rischi di pioggia
eccetera ma in realtà durante la festa
inizia a piovere
che cosa fai chiami di consegue di
blender perché lì si scaricherebbe
qualcosa che ricopra gli invitati dalla
pioggia
nessuno ci crede ok piatti paura di
rispondere bestemmi in tutte le lingue
conosce litighi con tua moglie per sé
per gli uomini dando nella colpa della
scelta della data e dell'ora quindi la
bestemmia va per la maggiore che è molto
bene mi scusi con gli invitati per
l'inconveniente chi vota questa tutti
bastardino vi scusate ma nessuno va bene
volta ok balli contro magistra pioggia
perché quello è il giorno più bello
della tua vita a qualche romanticone del
sostenendolo ok questa volta ed
azzeccate era l'ultima è il fallimento è
un po come la pioggia il giorno del tuo
matrimonio
tutte lo sei costruito nella tua mente
ai pensate un po al fin di che cosa si
sarebbe dovuto succedere
e invece la vita a volte non va come
l'avevamo programmata o come l'avevamo
pensata e quando però questo non succede
la reazione che viene spontanea è quella
che avete votato tutti non la bestemmia
e tutte le lingue del mondo e ti chiedi
perché perché proprio in quanto forte è
buono fossimo desiderio di avere
successo in questa iniziativa
imprenditoriale perché proprio a me deve
andare a mare
con quanto fosse buono questo mio
desiderio di far azienda nel mio caso è
quello che faceva sembra fare in modo
che le persone potessero avere più tempo
per fare ciò che sa ma non ho quindi
anche uno scopo nobile direi che non è
che costruiva costavamo armi o robero
eppure nonostante questo punto non
andata non andata bene e quando ho
capito questa cosa
ho voluto punto spiegare ai miei figli
che falliscono i progetti falliscono le
persone a rischio nelle aziende ma non
falliscono mai le persone questo perché
quando nokia è un punto che ho voluto
spiegare i figli di questa cosa del
fatto che la prima reazione è che viene
spontanea quella linea tutte le lingue
del mondo e grazie poi appunto i miei
figli e la mia famiglia ho avuto
l'ispirazione la forza di ripartire di
andare avanti e di fare questa video
fiaba da cui poi sono nate centinaia di
nuove opportunità da cui oggi riparto
riparto dal fatto che questa video fiaba
ho capito essere un format che funziona
che può funzionare
e adesso sono dei media ci sono delle
aziende ci sono delle personaggi che mi
stanno chiedendo di usare questo format
della fiaba per raccontare altre storie
riparto anche da da un nuovo lavoro
quando pubblica questa fiaba ho ricevuto
tantissime richieste se di
collaborazione anche di lavoro sono
stato contento di accogliere la
richiesta di accettare la richiesta di
questa azienda che si chiama il boom di
cui oggi ricomprare ruolo di direttore
generale
prima scherzando dice voce adesso faccio
l'imprenditore ma quei soldi degli altri
sono loro a mettere i soldi io più o
meno cerco di portarla avanti come
meglio riesco però questa è stata una
delle chiavi da qui sono ripartito anche
perché il lavoro che avevo trovato prima
sono riuscito anche a ri perderlo dopo
tre mesi quindi insomma o portofino
comunque è invece in questo questo 21
antonio cosa stanno andando bene grazie
a questa fiaba ho ricevuto quest'anno
offerte tra cui questa è oggi sto
cercando di dare il mio contributo in
questa azienda che ho scelto perché mi
piaceva l'azienda mi piace al prodotto e
lavorandoci dentro ho capito che sono
riuscito non solo a portare le mie
competenze ma che sono già da cary
sfruttare quel know how che avevo
imparato la mia esperienza insinua che
quindi non è andata perduta ha portato
comunque o sta portando ovunque del
valore entrato nell'azienda carice che
opera più o meno nello stesso settore
perché una fidelity payment ap c'è
un'applicazione che sarà a fidelizzare i
clienti dei negozi e aumenta il potere
d'acquisto delle persone quindi anche
qui non facciamo armi ma cerchiamo di
dare un valore aggiunto alle persone e
poi infine riparto da da un libro un
libro qui te che non ancora fatto che
farò in partirai una campagna card
panini in autunno e un libro cui tengo
tantissimo perché un libro di 100 fiabe
di 100 personaggi che hanno vissuto un
fallimento da qui però sono ripartiti e
alcune di queste storie sono storie che
ho letto in quei periodi insomma più
difficili dopo il fallimento in cui
punto mi chiedevo perché mi fosse
chiesto a me questo sacrificio queste
cose così difficile e leggere le storie
di persone che noi sud ei fallimenti
anche molto più pesanti dolorosi dei
miei da cui però poi sono ripartiti
dalla sua mania di successi questo mi è
stato molto utile quindi penso che è
stata questa cosa è stato utile a me
possa essere utile magari anche
tante le persone e soprattutto i bambini
questo motivo per cui voglio farlo
proprio come libro di fiabe cento fiabe
di questi 100 personaggi tra cui non ci
saranno solo in aziende imprenditori
falliti ma anche fallimenti personali
della vita mi piacerebbe raccontare
anche storie sicuramente di steve jobs
di michael jordan sono la gente famosa
in tutto il mondo ma anche fallimenti
come possono essere quelli di zanardi o
bebe vio che è un certo punto della loro
vita senza aver sbagliato qualcosa
quindi senza una colpa vera e propria si
sono ritrovati però di fronte a farsi la
stessa domanda no perché proprio io
perché zanardi che da un lato si trovato
senza gambe poteva dire cavolo ma perché
proprio io e invece lui è riuscito a
trasformare il successo questa cosa
insomma spero che questo libro possa
essere utile per questo prima di
concludere voglio far vedere un breve
video dura pochissimi secondi che
riassume un po tutte le cose che ho
detto oggi probabilmente avrei potuto
inviarmi costruito senza neanche venire
ma mi sembrava brutto insomma rifiutare
un invito a un ted quindi il prestigio
di questo palco mi sembra provenire però
vi farei vedere questo video di pochi
secondi perché appunto riassume un po il
concetto e così ho detto prima un po
datato quindi insomma quelli tra non
esatte del contenuto non è esattamente
un full hd però c'è questo bambino
perché vedete nella lente di
ingrandimento che che una recita
scolastica scolastica quindi davanti a
centrare i genitori che deve battere con
un'ascia che non so se riuscita
riconoscere un ascia su
[Musica]
nella lettera a un certo punto di sasha
si rompe ma la sua azione non è
bloccarsi a mettersi a piangere
magari avrebbe potuti opera con un
campaccio con la spiaggia sorride e
cerca di aggiustare non questa cha poi
prima non a chi veloce per 10 12 ad
aggiustarla pound somma una smorfia un
pool di capendo che sicuramente non
riesce ad aggiustare la lascia cadere ma
va avanti a battere anche se lascia è
rotta la continua ad utilizzare questo
perché nella sua smente semplice di
bambino non aveva questo preconcetto
nella propria testa di dire io sono
stato messo via battero nascesse
lasciano si rompe
come faccio mai riuscito invece ad
adattarsi a quello che la realtà gli ha
imposto di fronte no perché la realtà è
più forte di noi e ha detto se lascia è
rotta o in palo perché la gente che mi
sta guardando mi fermo e metto a
piangere
oppure ma sì chi se ne frega lab atto
anche se rotta
non so se qualcuno ha capito chiara
questo bambino ero io effettivamente che
assomiglio al mio figlio più grande con
la solita faccia insomma un po così
prima dice volevo salutarvi augurandovi
intanto di tornare a somma essere
semplici come i bambini e quindi non
avere questi preconcetti ma soprattutto
a quelli di non cercare di non fallire
mai ma di riuscire sempre a rialzarmi da
ogni vostro fallimento trasformandolo in
successo grazie
[Applauso]
io siccome ho avanzato qualche come
avanzato qualche secondo di tempo vi
avevo portato una versione breve di due
minuti che mi ha fatto mediaset di
questa fiaba per l'altra parte della
sala che la fiamma non l'aveva ancora
vista poi sui social trovate quella
intera dura sette minuti una noia
mortale per la gente l'ha vista tutta la
gatti lettura condivisa questa l'ha
fatta mediaset quindi è molto più bella
e soprattutto molto più breve e vela
condivido volentieri se parte mesi era
un ragazzino vivace chiamava l'oceano e
voleva diventare il capitano di una nave
un bel giorno decise di salpare con il
suo amico joy joy voglio partire disse
lesi
voglio portare lo scrigno magico che mi
ha regalato in un padre dall'altra parte
del mondo
poi aggiunse vieni con me ho bisogno di
un compagno che conosca mare le correnti
i due partiranno prolungo rischioso
viaggio ed iniziarono a reclutare
marinai esperti che li aiutassero in
questa impresa
daisy joy non avevano di che pagare e
per monti quel viaggio era troppo
pericoloso ma i due amici non si
scoraggiarono certi che il vero
fallimento sarebbe stato quello di non
partire
dopo 20 mesi di viaggio l'equipaggio era
stanco e le provviste stavano terminando
ma finalmente quando tutto sembrava
perduto e l'equipaggio stava morendo di
fame
ecco che approdarono sulla più bella
delle isole che avevano visitato ad
accoglierli fu il re in persona
riccardo esclamarono daisy joy siamo
giovane equipaggio molto affamato e
abbiamo affrontato diverse tempeste
giorni di sole per arrivare fin qui e la
metà è ancora lontana
e qui vivere che mi avete chiesto non vi
basteranno per arrivare dall'altra parte
del mondo
ma se userete bene vi aiuteranno ad
arrivare alla vostra prossima meta
buon viaggio dopo alcuni mesi di
navigazione però i viveri cominciarono
nuovamente a scarseggiare
come se non bastasse nuove tempeste si
erano abbattute sulla nave
danneggiandola pesantemente
i pochi marinai rimasti si rivolse
radesi joy con voce tremante capitano
siamo stanchi affamati
cari amici state sereni abbiamo
combattuto con tutte le nostre forze per
il successo nel nostro viaggio
domattina all'alba ricostruirò alla nave
chi vorrà potrà venire ad aiutarmi che
non appena sarà pronta partiremo per un
nuovo viaggio perché la luce dello
scrigno magico non si spenga mai
grazie
[Musica]